see out of Oregon the number 45
selection in the draft by Houston
Parker making everybody and then back to
dating Kyle Anderson
[Applause]
14 minutes nice to see Tony being able
to get to the basket in that situation
[Applause]
I told you to forget Google because he's
got all the answers right that's right
[Music]
[Applause]
on the shot clock for bills back to LA
with
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll take a saw at the last second mark
has eight now pile with two of these
brother battle
[Music]
Spears by 11 their largest lead a dozen
in the first half Aubrey's with 24
changed that 46 and a green hesitated on
the three spent on the shot clock for
Tony and Aldrich
[Music]
redhot nine on the shot clock Harrison
said wait a minute gives it off to the
big and then and Aldrich is there to
take care of Martin's shop tt for
Aldrich here inside drawing all kinds of
attention here and the Citiz - Ben got
out of position
- homage it's Marc Gasol dissolved at
about all you can do it can be a heck of
a defender and LS better back up
somebody's got a breakthrough
[Music]
a season-best for one milk do you see
that in this league though we have a big
day comes up with a defensive play she
locks it on one end and does a great job
running the floor and his reward a great
extra pass there by rudy Gay thread the
needle
Ginobili right back to Aldridge
[Applause]
la has just been an absolute monster
then this ball game was a stud 22 for
Tyreke Evans bills to already the paint
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]